one thing that can't be ignored is the
preseason and man have we seen the nfl
systematically cave on this
and it's it's significant because it's
rare
right it was a couple of weeks ago that
the nfl decided on its own to slash the
preseason from four games to two
the players said uh now we how about
none
how about no preseason games even though
the nfl has the power to determine the
number of preseason games can't be more
than four
can be as few as the nfl wants so the
nfl went from two
recently down to one i was told last
week by somebody on the league side of
the equation it is very likely there
will be one preseason game well again
the nfl
underestimated what the nflpa's resolve
was going to be on this
and ultimately nfl says
will will not do any preseason games
yeah and the nflpa
spokesman georgia tala kind of pushed
back last night against the perception
that the nfl offered
or conceded to have no preseason games i
mean basically the the union's position
is they
look they they have the power to
determine the number of season games
and they finally realized again it's the
smart thing to do it's the right thing
to do there's no upside
from having the risk of of moving guys
around from wherever they're going to be
between now and the start of the regular
season there's no revenue to be captured
from it
let's just not do it at all and i'm i
was amazed
that the nfl uh gave in
on this issue after digging in their
heels for as long as they did chris well
i mean you're right you don't see them
cave on anything really you know really
and especially when they do cave you
don't see it right you know i don't want
to say cave but
you know when they do you know adhere or
concede to what the players want right
uh it's shocking and especially at the
the pace of the way this happened you're
right i thought the owners were gonna
try to force feed this whole preseason
thing and
and really you know give the players a
hard time but i think the point you make
is
it's one of the first times really in
nfl history the players have
ultimate power here you know they really
do and i think the nfl owners know that
and then also i think the nfl owners
realize they probably come off looking
you know somewhat money hungry and
sensitive whatever it may be and i know
there's going to be no fans in the
stands if there was preseason games but
i just don't think it was going to be a
good look for them either
and at the end of the day mike still i'm
gonna go back to this point
you know first off most coaches coaches
in football don't even have like
all the rules and regulations for how
they have to coach their team yet
and then we're gonna talk about
preseason football three weeks from now
with guys that would no you know for one
i like i said yesterday are not going to
be in tip top ready to go football shape
and then two you know i don't think the
coaches are going to be able to move the
players along in the
speed and manner that they normally can
especially at first
because they're gonna have to figure out
this new formula
you know if an offensive line group has
you know let's say 12 guys in a meeting
room
from what i know right now all 12 of
those offensive linemen aren't going to
be in the same meeting room at the same
time they're not going to be allowed
so they're going to have to find ways to
split up coaches split up guys and do
different things
and of course that's going to be tough
on the coaching staff to where
they might not be able to cram as much
knowledge and technique and things like
that
into players in the same amount of time
as they usually can during a training
camp and i think
you know that was another big thing for
me and i'm glad to see they got rid of
the preseason because like you said it's
stupid and it's just uh you're rolling
the dice
well and one of the things the nflpa
wanted was no 11 on 11 activities of any
kind
i've seen nothing about that to confirm
that that's going to happen
now maybe it was something that the
nflpa was going to surrender as they
went through this bargaining exercise
again last night georgia tala with some
tweets tried to make it look like it
wasn't full-blown
back and forth negotiation with with
each side conceding something and it was
that's how it worked that's why it took
so long
this wasn't let's come together and
solve problems it was let's come
together and negotiate and so for
everything that we give you
we want something back and did the nflpa
give up
this notion of having no 11 on 11
activities of any kind i know that
coaches were concerned about that
because
it's a critical teaching that's right
well especially if you can't have
meetings the way you ordinarily would
most of the meetings if not all of them
are going to happen through video
conference once guys go home
you get guys out on the field in a
walk-through setting that's how you show
them what they're supposed to do
when the game goes live and again i
think until we see
because it'll be a big deal if it
happens until we see or hear that there
won't be 11 on 11 activities we assume
that there will be
and i think there's a way to do them
safely you don't have to huddle
together before the play and maybe you
could even do splits a little bit wider
on the offensive line this is all about
showing people what they do
when the time comes to snap you don't
have to be
shoulder to shoulder necessarily to show
a guy what he's supposed to do when it's
time to go
no i mean i i hear you there um
but but like first off i think the thing
is you got to have 11 on 11 football
just no way it actually i'd be worried
about the players again and
it's a safety issue you gotta you go i
don't you know
khalil mack and von miller and
zach martin and ronnie stanley and aaron
rodgers and patrick
they don't need practice or 11 on 11.
they're good enough to
probably never have 111 on 11 drill the
whole training camp
and they're going to be one of the
better players in football come the
start of the regular season
but that's just not the case with most
most players it's not that's a special
few on every team
and especially the young guys just think
about rookies or second year guys
it's a totally different game for them
they came from college football some
from small schools
and now they're out there on a college
football all-star game
with like you know pro bowlers and
superstars going holy cow this is a
whole different
you know stress on my body my mind they
need to have the 11 on 11.
and hey listen i mean i don't know i
mean we've seen all the
we saw the old line summit we've seen
lots of guys working out nobody seems to
have a problem huddling
anywhere else so why can't we huddle on
the football field when you're getting
tested on a daily basis too
so i just as a player here's why yeah
okay go ahead here's why
here's why it's it's it's a simple
proposition
because even if you're being tested on a
daily basis
you don't know on any given day whether
or not the guy next to you was positive
because the test that he just gave on
the way in
you don't get the result until the next
day right that's the
that's the danger in all of this and and
again back in may there was a belief in
league circles that by the time we got
to august and september
they'd be able to do a swab of the
inside of the mouth
they'd have a result within 30 45
minutes
tops we aren't there yet we may get
there during football season and if that
happens everything changes
but until then yeah there's still a
chance
that that there's going to be a crack
that someone slips through who is
positive
who is shedding virus actively and that
guy next to you in the huddle may be the
one who's doing it you may be the one
who's doing it
that's the reality here and that's why
these number one they wanted daily
testing because
there's no way to account for that
loophole but even with daily testing
you can't fully account for that
loophole chris yeah i i you're right
and and again i would hope that it could
maybe be faster than that
i do you know i'll i'll use my own
personal experience here once again
you know when i got tested you know 10
days ago or 11 days ago
right it was uh 9 45 am test mic
and i got the results by like 2 50
in the afternoon so i mean it's there
obviously i'm just saying i'm just
throwing it out there that maybe like
to prove your point that hopefully that
could be a quicker process here
going forward but the other thing too
you know and
this is this is something that's huge
you know the preseason
hey most coaches and organizations their
53-man roster
i would say on a given year going into
training camp and this is a little bit
of a different year as we know
they know about 46 to 47 of the guys
that are gonna make the team already
before training camp goes on
they know it's only about five or six
guys that they're going ooh do we want
to keep this fifth receiver or this
fifth receiver
do we want to keep this fifth defensive
back or this fifth defensive back
it's just a few of them and to me where
i get i'll just feel really bad is the
preseason being taken away
is going to hurt some of those guys who
you know maybe perform better
in a game than compared to practice or
whatever it may be and they're not going
to get that opportunity to show people
and do that and it's just going to be a
weird year for all those young unproven
guys i feel bad for them
because if i'm the coach i'm not i don't
want to mess with a lot of those guys
i i hear you and and i got a couple of
things the same response that we i mean
we always focus on those guys
but the reality is every one of those
guys that makes the 53-man roster
takes the job away of somebody else so
it's a zero-sum game you got 90 guys 30
37 are going away and this year of all
years
there's a pretty good chance that some
of those 37 are going to come back at
some point
they're going to have a 16 person
practice squad at least that's what the
nfl was proposing last week
very liberal and open rights to move
guys up and down
even after the rosters lock on saturday
afternoon at 4pm
up until 90 minutes before kickoff the
way the nfl has proposed it
you can bring up to 16 guys from the
practice squad onto the roster if
there's an
outbreak and then you know you have guys
who are going to be on the short term
covet 19 list they're actually going to
be on the commissioner exempt
list which we used to hear about all the
time and still do from time to time as
it relates to
personal conduct policy issues there
will be roster spots that need to be
filled then
so guys who gets sent away are going to
have an opportunity
at some point to come back and here's
the other thing too chris
and this is why they need to be careful
about 11 on 11.
you take away the opportunity of the
bottom of the roster guy
to prove himself in the preseason where
he gonna prove him
that's what i mean right so you just go
with the proven commodity already
no no here's my point yeah when you get
in 11 on 11 setting
you know that mindset that kind of rough
and tumble i'm gonna go
pop somebody in the mouth i'm gonna go
lay somebody out i'm going to do
more than what the coach wants i'm going
to go start a fight because maybe
that'll
impress the coach yeah you got you're
going to have to worry about keeping
those guys under control
because even in a walk through you're
going to have to worry about somebody
taking a shot at someone to try to get
noticed
before the roster cuts from 90 to 53.
yeah it's a it's a valid point mike
i've i've never really thought about it
but you're right you're going to have
guys who are going to go well
this might be my only opportunity to
impress coach here
i'm going to try to knock ezekiel hell
elliott's head off as he goes through
the hole even though i'm an undrafted
rookie or whatever it may be
you're right you get they're going to
have to be careful it's going to be have
to be the right balance
certainly and it's another reason why i
think they need to kind of take it slow
to get guys
ready as far as you know in shape
training
slowly get into the physical contact and
do things like that
you know the one thing i want to bring
up too mike because i know you just hit
on it
and i know i told you this last week i
believe uh when we were
talking for for a few minutes but the
the sense i've gotten from some of my
friends around the nfl
you know that they have gotten the feel
that
the owners feel like if they can keep
you know single digits outbreaks on the
team as long as they can keep it in
single digits below 10.
i think the owners feel that they think
they're going to maybe be able to
survive
uh any given week as long as it's lower
than that
and you know just interesting and you
know the way you think about it with the
extra guys on the roster and the
practice squad
maybe they can but uh i i wonder what
that line of demarcation is to where it
becomes oh no we can't get a team
and okay we can handle four or five guys
being sick
well i i think if you get much beyond
ten you do have a problem
because you only have 16 immediate
replacements especially if it happens
close in time to a game
it's just amazing to think that yeah on
march 11
one positive test for rudy gobert of the
utah jazz
shutdown basketball hockey baseball
everything
one positive with no symptoms one
positive shut it all down
and now we're like yeah you know as long
as we have fewer than 10 positives at
any given time
we'll be okay i'll tell you what here's
the thing that could shut it all down
and let's hope we don't find
out if somebody connected to the nfl
player
coach whoever trainer anyone who's in
that that team by team bubble
if somebody gets covered 19 and dies i
think that's when it's all over
oh i i i i you know i mean and and you
have to account for that possibility
no it happens no doubt now i think
they'll move heaven and earth to give
every anyone who shows symptoms the best
possible care
n to keep them alive number one because
it's the right thing to do but number
two
someone high up on the nfl food chain is
going to be thinking
this if something like this happens
we're done yeah that's
it but i think and it's just amazing to
think where we've come
from march to now that one positive test
shuts down four sports
and there's kind of this loose
acceptance that the only thing that's
going to shut down the nfl at this point
other than having
40 guys wiped out with a positive test
overnight
would be somebody uh uh succumbing to
the
virus so uh hopefully that will never
happen
to anyone connected to the nfl but the
reality is it's happening coast to coast
every day
and we hope to get to a point where it's
no longer part of our lives whether it's
making people sick or or worse
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc sports